einen herzlichen gruß aus zeltweg mein
name ist sebastian krahnert dienstgrad
hauptmann ich bin der
sicherheitskoordinator bei der flug
veranstaltung airpower
2022 als dieser bin ich verantwortlich
die sicherheit aller art besucherinnen
zuschauerinnen die sich am
veranstaltungsgelände befinden zu
jederzeit zu gewährleisten
bei möglichen krisenszenarien muss man
prinzipiell zwei unterscheiden
einerseits einen vorfall im bereich der
freightliner diese freiheit leyen ist
für flugzeuge nicht gestattet zu
überfliegen dass ein überfliegen der
zuschauer nicht passiert in so einem
szenario wäre eine und flucht über
norden
unzulässig somit nur über süden möglich
beziehungsweise osten um teilbereiche im
westen bei einem krisenszenario einer
bedrohungslage auf dem
veranstaltungsgelände direkt
beispielsweise durch einen
terroristischen anschlag ist es möglich
die freightliner binnen kürzester zeit
die dort vorhandene absperrung
abzubauen das eine entfluchtung über
norden sowie süden und alle vorhandenen
fluchtwege und korridore möglich gemacht
wird sollte es tatsächlich zu einer
räumung kommen wird dies über dem blatt
sprecher kommuniziert und binnen
kürzester zeit müssen die vereinzelung
anlagen in einer zugangsbereich die für
die personen- und gepäckkontrollen
notwendig sind abgebaut und zu paketen
zusammen gestellt werden anschließend
werden die besucher durch das speziell
geschulte personal sicher vom gelände
geleitet
wir haben uns bestmöglich vorbereitet
die sicherheit aller besucher hinzu
jederzeit gewährleisten zu können sollte
es tatsächlich zu einem zwischenfall
kommen dann versuche ich die anweisungen
des eingesetzten personals zu befolgen
und dann steht einer sicheren air power
2022 nichts mehr im wege